bonsoir les titres tout de suite
soulagement en bosnie le convoi
humanitaire de l'onu est enfin arrivé à
srebrenica avec le général morillon à sa
tête
fin de campagne électorale ce soir en
france dernier reportage dans ce journal
est une question y at il encore un
suspense football psg contre juventus de
turin et auxerre contre dortmund ce sont
les demi finales de la coupe européenne
de l'uefa
et puis du ski victoire d'un français
dans une descente de coupe du monde en
norvège un français aux noms déjà
célèbre adrien duvillard la bonne
nouvelle est donc enfin arriver dans le
courant de l'après midi et c'est un
énorme soulagement pour toute la
population d'une de toute une ville
celle de srebrenica en bosnie là bas des
milliers de personnes vous le savez
était en train de mourir de faim mais
grâce à la ténacité du général morillon
commandant en chef des forces de l'onu
le convoi humanitaire de l'onu a pu
enfin arrivé à destination après bien
des difficultés françois corner ça n'a
pas été simple en effet sur le chemin de
ce très bel ichaï jusqu'au dernier
moment il aura fallu parlementer
louvoyer convaincre les serbes sont
toutefois se laisser intimider mais sans
agression d'une violence essayer à tout
prix de passer la preuve le convoi de
l'espoir est arrêté pour la énième fois
un officier les casques bleus essaient
de dissuader un soldat serbe
armé d'une kalachnikov de se mettre à
travers du chemin celui-ci s'écarter se
met en position de défense le canot en
l'air mais la main sur la gâchette
le soldat est un parachutiste des forces
spéciales un professionnel philippe
morillon le général courage comme on l'a
surnommé intervient il discutait
disputent encore il sourit il plaisante
il en a encore la force
on va attendre encore un peu il faut
bien si l'on a une chance de pouvoir
sauver les habitants de shah deniz chat
de la famille elle se joue maintenant
avec toute la patience la diplomatie le
courage du général morillon 16h les 175
tonnes de vivres et de médicaments sont
toujours bloqués à moins d'une trentaine
de kilomètres du but 16h30 l'espoir va
renaître le général morillon a obtenu à
l'arraché un nouveau départ du convoi
il n'y a plus de temps à perdre dit il
comme on le comprend
encore une fois sans précipitation comme
si tout cela était en fait normal il va
reprendre la tête du convoi direction
serait banni cha son témoignage en fin
de soirée par liaison amateur depuis
srebrenica
mission accomplie pour le général
morillon mais pour lui elle n'est pas
terminée il ne veut pas quitter ce rêve
et nietzsche a tant que la protection de
la ville n'est pas assurée par les
casques bleus
le reste de l'actualité avec en france
peut-être les pilotes d'une douloureuse
affaire judiciaire le 4 juin prochain
ce jour là guillaume seznec sera
peut-être réhabilité il y avait été
envoyé au bagne en 1924 pour le meurtre
d'un homme qu'il a toujours nié tout au
long de sa vie depuis des années son
petit fils denis se bat pour sa
réhabilitation est ce matin denis était
entendu par la commission de révision
maryse burgot espoir et émotion
c'était ce matin le rendez vous de sa
vie des années de combat et là denis
seznec c'est qu'il n'a que quelques
heures pour convaincre les juges
les convaincre de l'innocence de son
grand père la commission a fait
vous dis comme ça une très bonne
impression parce que j'ai l'impression
d'avoir des gens de bonne foi mais
c'était très dur
attendez de ce qu'on attendait de
seconde ne jamais pleuré devant les
autres ça denis seznec le tient de son
grand-père s'étonne qui un jour de 1927
pris la marinière le bateau des forces à
celui qui menait au bagne guillaume
seznec condamné aux travaux forcés à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de pierre
quéméneur conseiller général du
finistère un crime qu'il ne cessa jamais
deniers 1947 16 nec entame sa vingtième
année de bagnes quand il est gracié par
de gaulle
c'est un vieil homme qui retrouve sa
fille sa famille
peut-il imaginer que demain ce petit
fils qu'il tient dans ses bras se battra
pour sa réhabilitation
c'est une famille qui s'est regroupée
autour d'une injustice ma famille est
une famille m'a retiré et je crois que
le minimum qu'on lui doit c'est de
continuer à combattre pour obtenir cette
cette reconnaissance comme quoi on a
fait une terrible injustice en 1924
qu'on donne à mon grand père il en est
convaincu
son grand père n'a jamais tué quemeneur
il n'a jamais fait de faux papiers pour
s'approprier le domaine de tra oneze
lyonnaise ne sera pourtant condamné
soupçonné dès le début de l' enquête
parce qu'il fut le dernier à voir
quemeneur condamné d'avancé par une
instruction qui retiendra surtout les
témoins à charge des témoins qui parfois
se rétracte comme le fait aujourd'hui
louise mitrani seznec coupable idéal qui
permet peut-être d'étouffer le scandale
politique qui couve une histoire de
trafic de cadillac dans laquelle était
impliqué le conseiller général quemeneur
seznec innocent répète inlassablement
son petit-fils à la recherche de
l'honneur perdu de son grand père
encore du nouveau dans la sphère botton
cette fois la justice qui jusqu'à ce
jour s'était préoccupé des largesses de
l'homme d'affaires lyonnais s'interroge
maintenant sur les revenus de pierre
botton et un homme est maintenant viser
c'est le pdg d'une société de
distribution d eau qui aurait versé
beaucoup d'argent à monsieur botton
michele finn explique
le huitième personnage mises en examen
dans le cadre de la sphère botton est un
chef d'entreprise de la région lyonnaise
marc michel merlin et le pdg de la sdei
société de distribution d eau
intercommunale cette entreprise filiale
de la lyonnaise des eaux depuis janvier
91 est soupçonné d'avoir fait des
fausses factures
il ya quelques mois les policiers ont
découvert sur le compte personnel de
pierre botton à la société générale des
versements réguliers en 1990 de la sdei
total trois millions sept cent trente
cinq mille neuf cent francs coïncidence
en janvier 1991 pierre botton se
présentait aux législatives partielles à
lyon interrogé sur le bien fondé de ces
versements le gendre de michel noir a
expliqué qu'il avait effectués pour la
sdei des études de marché sur les pays
de l'est l'afrique du sud ou la turquie
entendu à son tour le 16 février marc
michel merle à a produit les documents
en question en fait il s'agit davantage
de compilation de coupures de presse que
d'études de marché ces explications
n'ont en tout cas pas convaincu le juge
d'instruction
le réquisitoire du parquet de lyon lui
ouvre désormais un nouveau champ
d'investigation celui du financement et
des fausses factures
une nouvelle forme d'action sociale
lancée par la cgt en seine maritime pour
lutter contre des licenciements annoncés
dans une usine de sotteville-lès-rouen
le syndic a en effet décidé de lancer
une campagne de boycott contre les
produits fabriqués par cette usine en
l'occurrence les produits sopalin
frédéric crotta jean yves dusserre
hier il écumait les meetings politiques
aujourd'hui se tourner en désespoir de
cause vers le consommateur personne ne
veut parler d'un boycott de leurs
propres produits
mais cela y ressemble fin novembre
kimberly-clark annonce un plan de
restructuration le 17 février 312 10 en
ciment sur 470 salariés et je vais
gagner toute mon énergie et je faisais
chavanon toute mon énergie là dedans du
sucre et ses retranchements au coeur à
savoir que que ce matériel qu'on a
maîtrisé par moments la bichonner on se
casser la tête de sucre certes on peine
vicieuse ce matériel va être démonté la
sandale et mais ce que veut la direction
américaine c'est que l'usiné fabrique
plus qu'un seul produit avec 150
salariés seulement et quelques machines
en moins on voudrait le garder il
l'avait dans un plan dont j'avais
plusieurs plans et si on regardait ça
préserverait 70 emplois et qui ont comme
sap qui permettrait de garder des femmes
parce que c'est les femmes sont
pratiquement toutes licenciées et se
règlerait aussi les cas sociaux
alors on a décidé de se battre
des assemblées générales toutes les
semaines on s'occupe comme on peut mais
dans un esprit de solidarité
la direction a refusé de nous recevoir
elle ne communique principalement que
pas presse locale interposés à certains
on a déjà proposé des congés de
conversion mais rien n'est signé encore
alors on est prêt à se battre jusqu'au
bout
les mesures pour les pêcheurs le
secrétaire d'état à la mer charge cela
va mettre en oeuvre une compensation
exceptionnelle à leur manque à gagner
réplique immédiate des marins pêcheurs
ce n'est pas suffisant il faut des
mesures structurelles la politique jour
j - 2 avant les élections c'est dimanche
que les français votent pour le premier
tour des élections législatives
la campagne officielle se termine donc
ce soir à minuit suite et fin de la
campagne électorale sur le terrain
direction tout de suite le loir et cher
la première circonscription celle de
blois c'est celle de jack lang
le ministre a face à lui une opposition
divisée françois brabant jacques gérard
reportage
parfois jack lang se fait tout petit si
dimanche dernier tout bois et est en
liesse
ça n'était pas pour lui mais pour le
carnaval ça tombe bien monsieur le maire
fait campagne en douceur un peu de
discrétion beaucoup de subventions
c'est la recette pour faire de beaux à
une ville culturelle et touristique
restauration du château maison de la
magie pour jack lang tout ça ça compte
d'ailleurs jean cocteau est d'accord
avec lui il disait il n'y a pas d'amour
il ya seulement des preuves d'amour je
dirais les beaux discours
ça ne compte pas beau ce qui compte ce
sont les preuves concrètes de ce qu'on
est soi même c'est à dire ses actes et
je demande qu'on me juge sur mes actes
et gt ou non un bon ministre ait été ou
non un bon maire à ces questions
essentielles jacqueline gourault répond
catégoriquement non candidate de la
droite
elle ne cache pas que certains dans
l'opposition locale s'accommode plutôt
bien de la cohabitation avec le maire de
blois ça n'est pas son cas cette
enseignante n'a qu'une cible son
ministre je ne mène pas un combat anti
jacques lang je mène un combat contre
jacques lang
les habitants de cette circonscription
veulent ta changement et je suis prêt
pas incarner ce changement pour demain
mais voilà jacqueline gourault dans
cette campagne n'a pas qu'un seul
adversaire
jacky des forges lui a déclaré la guerre
boucher de son état candidat indépendant
de centre droit comme il le dit lui-même
est très appréciée dit on du rpr local
jacky des forges règle ses comptes
je ne peux admettre que paris nous
impose une candidate giscardienne à
travers la personne de madame jacqueline
gourault à la diviser l'opposition
la preuve en est à la fée bat le
président roger cau mer aux dernières
élections sénatoriales
si jack lang peut compter sur une
relative division à droite il devra en
revanche se passer du soutien des
écologistes nicole combres des a été
clair jamais je ne fais pas présent au
deuxième tour il est clair qu'il n'y
aura pas de désistement pol pelletier
front national et le communiste jean
louis le moing complètent la liste des
candidats mais la victoire se jouera
entre jacqueline gourault et jack lang
les blésois le reconnaissent leur mère
ministre a fait beaucoup pour sa ville
beaucoup trop même disent certains
les élections françaises vu de
l'étranger ce qui est sûr c'est que chez
nos voisins et partenaires ces élections
suscitent avis intérêts dans les pays
voisins on s'interroge d'ailleurs plus
sur la politique du futur gouvernement
que sur les résultats qui semble pour
beaucoup acquis première étape ce soir
londres christian marie maunoury should
know it is probably tout longue période
les hommes politiques français parlent
qu'anglais
les téléspectateurs britanniques en sont
convaincus la db6 les chaînes
indépendantes se sont davantage
intéressés à la situation sur le terrain
avec des préférences pour l'écologie ou
pour la campagne du leader du front
national à marseille
insistant sur les incidents émaillant la
campagne par exemple
c'est au cours d'un meeting du premier
ministre pierre bérégovoy
le britannique ont appris que les
candidats privilégiés les commerces et
les cafés et ont découvert avec surprise
une certaine familiarité de l'homme
politique français
la presse écrite dans son ensemble a
porté un jugement sévère sur 12 ans de
gouvernements de gauche
seul le 'financial times' crédite la
gestion socialiste d'un bon point le
quotidien de la city elle reste
convaincue que le franc restera une
monnaie forte
les élections françaises auront eu le
mérite de rappeler aux britanniques que
les problèmes économiques existent
ailleurs récession immigration chômage
mais quelle que soit l'issue les urnes
ou seulement elles sur leur camion de
moutons et de poisson pour en arriver en
france sans difficulté les élections
françaises vues par les allemands
maintenant deuxième étape berlin pascal
guimier antoine waechter en campagne à
la campagne une des rares images
paisibles que la télévision allemande
rares foot ce premier tour
notre orgueil national du team en
souffrir les législatives ne suscite ici
qu'une indifférence polie seul frisson
intérêt lorsque l'on parle des verts
mais là aussi sans illusion parce que
même avec un très bon pourcentage des
voix
il faut quand même gagné les sièges et
je pense que ce système électoral n'est
pas très juste
en comparaison de les voix données et
les sièges obtenus certes l'allemagne
mis sur un changement dans la continuité
pourtant sur certains dossiers délicats
les différences pourrait bien tourner
aux divergences exemple les négociations
du gatt sur le commerce international
ou bien la sempiternelles questions des
taux d'intérêt résultat prudence il y as
possibilité qu'un futur gouvernement
cherche le clash avec meet aurons avec
les présidents mitterrand et un clash
cesserait sur l'europe parce que
mettront aguettaz clairement dit là vous
touchez pas alors si quelqu'un veut
faire éclater la cohabitation avant le
temps ce serait sur l'europe gambas
battre et là il y aura des problèmes de
nouveau dans les relations franco
allemand
quoi qu'il en soit pour tenter
d'intéresser leur public nos malheureux
confrère recherche plutôt le
sensationnel les petites phrases d'un
michel rocard par exemple ne font pas le
poids à côté des écoutes placé chez un
journaliste du monde
monde où des échauffourées autour d'un
jean marie le pen même succès pour la
colère des marins pêcheurs qui a eu
droit aux honneurs du 20 heures
après tout ce n'est peut-être que
justice à chacun ses préférences
la france elle ne montre souvent de
l'allemagne que des néo nazis
dernière petite phrase de campagne celle
de jacques chirac c'était il ya quelques
minutes au club de la presse d'europe 1
monsieur chirac a parlé de la période de
cohabitation il estime qu' en période de
cohabitation il ne doit pas y avoir de
prééminence du président de la
république en matière de politique
étrangère
cinquante femmes campagne donc pour une
élection que certains estiment déjà joué
d'avancé
alors albert du roy une question est ce
qu'il y ait encore un suspense dans
cette élection ait eu une certitude
s'est en effet imposé durant la campagne
y compris dans le discours des
dirigeants socialistes celle d'une
victoire rpr udf cette certitude
concerne l'enjeu essentiel la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale mais elle ne doit
pas faire oublier quelques incertitudes
importantes incertitudes d'abord pour
les vainqueurs annoncés
obtiendront-ils une victoire d'adhésion
avec par exemple plus de 40% des voix ou
bien simplement un succès par défaut par
défaut dans un adversaire
deuxièmement de l'udf ou du rpr lequel
devancera l'autre avec à la clé le
fauteuil de matignon incertitudes
ensuite pour les socialistes
réussiront-ils à grappiller quelques
points par rapport à leur désastre des
régionales de l'an dernier 18 % leur
sinistrose est telle que les socialistes
en viendrait presque à considérer qu un
score supérieur à 20% ce ne serait plus
un échec
il ne faudra quand même pas oublier
qu'en 1988
dans la foulée de la réélection
présidentielle il avait obtenu 34%
dernière incertitude enfin les électeurs
qui auront déserté le parti socialiste
sans rejoindre l'udf rpr et qui
bouderont ainsi en bloc ce qu'on appelle
les partis de gouvernement
ces électeurs où iront ils vers les
extrêmes vers les écologistes ou bien
vers l'abstention
vous le voyez derrière une certitude
globale beaucoup de suspense dimanche
pour la soirée électorale de france 2
rendez vous donc dimanche 19h30 merci
albert dans la guerre commerciale entre
les états unis la communauté européenne
à légère espoir après la visite de
acte ii lors le président de la
commission à washington les américains
viennent en effet de décider de reporter
les sanctions américaines contre
certaines firmes européennes
fin de la visite de salman rushdie en
france dernières rencontres pour
l'écrivain britannique plus que jamais
menacée à mort par l'iran dernière
rencontre donc avec ces têtes avec
michel rocard l'ancien premier ministre
ensuite salman rushdie est reparti dans
la discrétion mais avec vous allez le
voir un cortège tout à fait
impressionnant pour cette courte visite
en france salman rushdie a été entouré
de mesures exceptionnelles de sécurité
mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
aussi en israël ce vendredi il faut dire
que c'est le dernier vendredi du ramadan
et les autorités craignent des incidents
entre juifs et musulmans depuis le début
du mois dernier il ya eu une telle vague
de violence en israël et dans les
territoires occupés par exemple 21
palestiniens tués et 13 israéliens tués
aussi philippe rochot une prière sous
haute surveillance devant la mosquée al
aqsa cent cinquante mille fidèles pour
ce dernier vendredi du mois de ramadan
sont venus se tourner vers la mecque
avec en toile de fond la colère qui ne
cesse de monter dans la bande de gaza à
mort et 25 blessés ce matin encore pour
la troisième journée consécutive l'armée
israélienne a ouvert le feu sur deux
jeunes manifestants palestiniens qui lui
jetaient des pierres
depuis le début du mois cinq
palestiniens ont été tués ici et six
israéliens l'un des bilans les plus
lourds depuis le début de l'intifada
à tel point que des voix s'élèvent en
israël pour dire que l'armée doit
quitter gaza
un débat s'est engagé je pense que ce
serait une erreur et un terrible
précédent de donner aux palestiniens
l'impression qu'on peut forcer israël à
partir sous les jets de pierres et les
coups de couteau des centaines de
milliers d'habitants de gaza dépendent
pour leur vie quotidienne de l'économie
israélienne
la rupture aurait de graves conséquences
pour les palestiniens il n'y aurait plus
d'eau à gaza dit on plus d'électricité
car c'est israël qui tient les commandes
de toute façon les cinq mille colons
juifs qui vivent dans les implantations
de la bande de gaza sont décidés à
rester si nous partons die stille ce
sera un nouveau sud liban aux portes
d'israël
l'homme par qui le scandale arrive dans
l'église catholique cet homme j'ai n'dré
vers man qui est à la fois prêtre et
psychanalyste fait en effet scandale en
allemagne par des prises de position
jugées très audacieuse par ses
supérieurs de l'église
il a même été suspendu par son évêque
mais ces livres sont des best-sellers et
pas seulement en allemagne son influence
s'étend maintenant à l'étranger ainsi
son ouvrage les fonctionnaires de dieu
qui vient juste d'être traduit en france
est déjà en tête sur la liste des
meilleures ventes
justement le père dre vers man est à
paris marc maisonneuve christian hottin
les raisons du scandale eugène riverman
un prêtre à part pour lui la foi est une
chose trop sérieuse pour la laisser aux
supérieurs de l'église
l'évangile dit il et la collection des
mythes religieux il utilise surtout la
psychanalyse pour lire la bible est
publiée à profusion dans son livre les
fonctionnaires de dieu vendu à 300 mille
exemplaires en allemagne
il traite le pacte de mesquins et
n'agace pas de jean paul ii son évêque
le suspens sans pouvoir le réduire au
silence
grosso et la dernière vraie question
soulevée par martin luther a été est ce
que les chrétiens doivent rester dans
l'église en accord avec le pape au
risque de perdre l'idée même de ce côté
dieu il devait en leur âme et conscience
en discuter clairement avec le pape et
prendre un risque
ce croisé d'un genre nouveau se vend
bien en france c'est déjà un succès
médiatique avant d'être un succès en
librairie
ils dénoncent les idéaux de l'église le
célibat chez les prêtres les voeux de
pauvreté d'obéissance emprisonne l'homme
selon lui un discours dérange en
l'église de france refusent très
officiellement de prendre position sur
le sulfureux de rêveurs man
c'est vrai que cet homme dit des choses
brutales l'enfer il y en a combien qui
essaie de lire on les écoute jamais on
dans l'église catholique
qu'est ce qui s'est produit on a cédé au
chantage de monseigneur lefebvre
et pendant ce temps là les fouleux fiche
le camp alors à quoi joue-t-on un jeu
que rome ne peut pas goûté la remise en
cause de l'autorité parrain de ce qu'il
a accepté pendant des années un de ceux
qui la connaît le mieux et qui peut
l'ébranler durablement le sport avec le
ski décidément ça va beaucoup mieux dans
le ski français après le titre de carole
merle au japon titre de championne du
monde voici qu'un français vienne gagné
une descente de coupe du monde en
norvège sur le lieu même des jeux
olympiques l'année prochaine
il s'agit ce français adria du billard
un nom mythique puisque adrien et le
fils d'adrien et le neveu de henri viard
si j'étais bruno masure je pourrais même
dire que pour faire un bon descendeur il
faut avoir une bonne ascendance bref
ajoutez à cela la deuxième place en
slalom de patricia chauve et
explications à la spv avec les secondes
qui s'égrènent et les casques qui cache
les visages le ski de haut niveau a
parfois quelque chose d'inhumain
et c'est bien dommage on aurait aimé
voir le minois de patricia sauvé à cet
instant précis de la course car on
ignorait peut-être discerner à sourire
elle est comme ça patricia à l'extérieur
elle frappe les piquets avec violence
tandis qu'à l'intérieur elle n'est que
calme et bonne humeur
troisième la semaine dernière elle rate
ici la première place pour 33 centièmes
de seconde seulement
ce qui n'empêchera pas je vous le disais
bien un souvenir adrien dubillard lui
n'avait pas le temps de rire vraiment
dans la descente qui sera l'an prochain
la descente olympique
surtout qu'il est chronométré à plus de
132 km heure adrien 6 adrien et neveux
d'henri n'a que 24 ans et depuis le
début de la saison il flirte avec les
premières places il lui manquait encore
un peu de confiance en lui cette fois il
a battu les grands et pour ceux qui n'en
sont pas convaincus
sympa en football belles perspectives
pour les clubs français les demi finales
de la coupe européenne de l'uefa la c3
opposeront psg à la juventus de turin et
auxerre au borussia de dortmund les
matches retour auront lieu en france
pourquoi pas alors une finale auxerre
psg en tout cas le football français a
connu sa plus belle semaine depuis fort
longtemps
couronné hier par la qualification du
psg après un suspense insoutenable
patrice romedenne on n'a pas fini
d'explorer les méandres du vocabulaire
et dans regretter les limites pour
conter l'histoire de cette qualification
tout au plus sait-on depuis hier soir
qu'il est question d'un certain bonheur
scénariste invisible d'une soirée
ciselés à la hitchcock
mais quel est donc ce beau leurre il
naît d'un frisson lorsque george weah
d'école
1 0 à la pause paris est dans les temps
dès lors l'illusion active le plaisir
cet embryon de bonheur auquel ginola
donne un sens
le parisien libère son geste le bonheur
à faire d'un instant j'ai présenté les
chiffres c'est payant c'est payant et
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelques temps je
répète contre le ballon essayer de
mettre un plat du pied mais je crois que
la plupart des buts je crois qui se
marque terme sans trop réfléchir avec un
effet un petit peu un petit peu bizarre
dernières minutes où l'on apprend qu'une
fois atteint le bonheur se peaufine
valdo 3-0 les arrêts de jeu où l'on se
convainc que le bonheur s'enrichit de
doute zamorano 3 1 les arrêts de jeu
toujours où l'on estime qu'à force
d'aguicher le bonheur fini par céder
antoine kombouaré 4 buts à 1 alors dans
cette bonbonnière de béton qu'est le
parc des princes il se passe ce qui
n'arrive qu'à une ou deux reprises par
décennie fois d'habitués quelque chose
d'un communicables et de bons que le
partage amplifie quelque chose de
sauvage comme un désir assouvi
hier soir le paris saint germain et son
public au fait l'amour la voile une
semaine après alain gautier le vainqueur
deux arrivées aujourd'hui d'un globe
challenge le vendée globe challenge
deuxième ce matin jean luc van den aide
un autre lorientais comme gauthier et
troisième set après midi philippe poupon
qui est arrivé m'a cassé fille boisserie
l'éclopé van den est vivait depuis
quelques jours la peur au ventre avec sa
voie d'eau sur le plan de son bateau au
petit matin ils pouvaient transformer
ces fusées de détresse en fusée de
liesse vdh
venez de boucler son tour du monde en
116 jours et 15 heures
troisième lors du premier vendée globe
deuxième aujourd'hui le prof de sciences
ne sera jamais premier
il ne courra pas la prochaine édition
tu crois pas parce que d'abord je suis
trop vieux trop vieux quand on fait le
tour du monde en solitaire à 47 ans il
faudra trouver autre chose
quelques heures plus tard même lieu même
joie l'accueil des embarcations salue le
troisième de la course
philippe poupon à bord de ce drôle de
voiliers ratatiner sur lui-même pour
cause de démâtage à quelques encablures
de l'arrivée tout qu'on n'a pas eu de
chance qu'ils cassaient au départ guinée
à l'arrivée avec une seconde place
soufflé sur le fil un peu amer à bord de
ce qu'il appelle sa péniche à voile
philippe poupon s'est néanmoins déclaré
heureux de ces quatre mois en mer et
demain grande après midi de sport sur
france 2 avec l'ami jean mamère à 18h en
direct la finale du championnat du monde
de handball ce sera france russie et
auparavant à partir de 15 heures ce sera
france gall mais en rugby
si les français gagnent ils remportent
le tournoi des cinq nations le capitaine
de l'équipe de france de rugby c'est
jean françois tordo un personnage
attachant
christophe duchiron egidra grille en
trace le portrait à la manière de la
fontaine la fable pourrait s'appeler le
joueur de rugby et le chien
jean françois tordo sur sa moto perché
tenait devant lui son chien klein
tu vas pas reçu ses commandes au boulot
non jeff est pas tout seul conducteur de
travaux
le meilleur ami du chien c'est hors
d'eau on a coutume de dire que la raison
du plus sympa et toujours la meilleure
ce sont quelques merguez que tordo à
porter et les ouvriers sont venus par
l'odeur alléchés bien sûr ça n'était pas
un festin de rois mais le régal fut fort
taux net
jean françois tordo est un homme affable
foi d'animal
c'est des moments intimes qu'on se
retrouve entre nous il ya des
capverdiens à les portugais bon chacun
parle un peu de son pays des anecdotes
tout ça c'est sympa quand on en a on
apprend découvrir des hommes est un pays
et c'est bien et bonjour monsieur
cordeau que vous êtes jolie que vous me
semblez beau ont mis les plus
qu'ailleurs rien ne sert de souffrir il
faut pousser à point
jean françois tordo il son compagnon
clyde en route vers la colline aux
animaux sur le lopin de terre familiale
il y à john linehan glay il y a deux
brebis de vache un peu plus loin et
beaucoup d'affection
on a beau jouer au rugby on n'est pas
des bêtes mais je vous présentais la
première ligne de l'équipe de france qui
joue un ventre et à 21% bonnes
sensations et alors en scène ici tiers
bordeaux et louisou armary ou quand j'ai
pas la chance d'être avec lui à les voir
tordo capitaine du quinze de france les
dirigeants au dessus du fleuve dont
alors comme chez jean de la fontaine il
ya une morale si le ramage de l'ain se
rapporte au pelage de l'autre à leur
tordo le joueur et clyde le chien ont
sans doute le même coiffeur voit la fin
de cette édition la météo dans un
instinct avec laurent romejko dernière
édition ce soir catherine ceylac vers
23h30 après bouillon de culture je vous
retrouve demain à 13 heures juste avant
l'émission géopolis l'émission de claude
thiriot qui demain sera consacrée au
peuple inuit un peuple du canada
bonne soirée sur france 2 à demain